[Music]
hi Conan O'Brien here with an important
message Valentine's Day is just around
the corner now some of you are nervous
you haven't made your plans yet that's
where I come in
I'd like to help we're gonna have a
special contest on our show that's right
we're you if you win you and your
partner your loved one can have a date
mere feet from Andy and I during the
taping of a show you'll have to be part
of the program I'm not gonna say exactly
what's gonna happen because a it's a
secret and B we've put no thought into
this we have no idea we'll make up
something at the last minute we're busy
the point is this is gonna be a lot of
fun all right so if you're interested
submit a video response with you and
your partner your loved one you all
special dude or later that exhibits your
creativity your interpersonal chemistry
and your table manners send us that
video and you could win a chance to have
a date mere feet from Andy and I all
right it's all called Conan's VD
explosion for Valentine's Day and we're
very excited about it and I look forward
to seeing you on that very special day
peace out
[Music]
[Applause]